what's happening there reject nation we
are going to watch the movie today a
movie that has been my go-to punchline
for so long and yet i've never seen this
movie ever i've never actually seen it
it's white chicks
classic film it's been on my list to to
eventually react to and the reason we
decided to go ahead and do it is because
uh we covered brooklyn 99 and something
went terribly wrong with our recording
and we won't be able to post that
reaction but then i heard terry crews is
really good in this so i thought you
know what instead of doing a 20-minute
show that we were not able to deliver to
you guys well instead cover a whole
movie just because terry crews out here
is hilarious in this film and i've heard
the movie's actually pretty funny i
don't know why i've never taken the time
to watch this movie before underrated
gem so sorry about that we'll continue
brooklyn nine-nine next week there'll be
one episode missing in the archives
unfortunately but if you can leave a
like that'd be very much appreciated
subscribe and click that notification
bell to get notified when our next movie
reaction is up also thanks to the boys
of prep for helping us edit this down
and of course full length watch alongs
for all the super sexy rejects over at
our patreon page along with a bunch of
other shows that we cover let's get to
it
[Music]
[Applause]
i did grow up watching the wayans
brothers show to have some of that
nostalgia you got me into the
waynesboros growing up my favorite was
always marlin where's manny tell him
the ice cream man is here
fbi you're under arrest
it's two sexiest fbi agents tell money
is ice cream delivery is here
oh he sells actual ice
oh
never mind wrong store
[Laughter]
the ice cream now i'm tired of the
escapades i want them to stop the last
thing i need is to be the laughing stock
of the bureau and furthermore the
i'm checking with the bureau to see if
they got any openings
in
all right
time and place
way to go basking in robin hey lachlan
monroe
i can't believe you had me sitting here
all night worried about you
it's only eight o'clock
they are the kidnappers next victim now
the wilson sisters will be flying into
jfk this morning
so who's going to pick him up what
marcus has something you want to tell
you
[Laughter]
we just want to know if we could get on
the case you're on
[Laughter]
decently funny editing in here all we
got to do is pick these chicks up drop
their ass off in the hamptons and then
we back in the chief's good graces i
want to be out on the street where the
action is okay blackie chan and you'll
get there but can we just do this first
please blocky chin now cause you know
i'm lactose intolerant last time i
barely made it to the bathroom man why
would i want to disturb your stomach oh
that's gonna come back later
[Music]
hi i'm kevin copeland we already gave
the united negra fund oh my gosh
you were thinking it i know what you
said i know i know and you know heather
totally hates you because you slept with
her boyfriend my god
no oh my god
oh my god your lip oh my god your nose
are you okay
i'm cool
why'd you have the window down you think
we're gonna go to the hamptons with my
face looking like that
who is that she's so familiar there are
girls i've met who are like this i am so
freaking pissed
i'm gonna have bf wait hey what's a bf
she's gonna have a [ __ ] fit oh no look
that's how me and kevin want to tell you
yeah uh yeah chief hey
uh yeah me and marcus just we we just
wanted to thank you for the opportunity
man no we did yeah
[Laughter]
he lied to me oh yeah yeah oh if i don't
have man three hours i'll cut him off
and mail to you myself
all right take care
oh you know them girls ain't gonna be
there
oh they'll be there
[Laughter]
where are the white women at let's do
this
[Music]
i love how they resort to this instead
of just trying to fix up their little
cuts
it's the only logical solution
[Music]
movie typing
[Music]
this is like face off
yo what's up money you got a problem
what you looking at my ass for
nah yo hold my poodle hold my poodle hey
yo what's up y'all got a problem
sweetie
you've got to slow up with those cosmos
i need a credit card please
and some id please
id
i'm so
freaking pissed
first of all i go to doctor dorfman he
totally messes up my nose job
he sounds like an old jewish woman
[Laughter]
enjoy your stay has anyone ever told you
look just like denzel washington
oh yeah
really i
have heard it once
[Laughter]
that was
[Music]
karen lisa tori
karen
no wait a minute
there is
definitely
something different about the two of you
collagen
how did you know
that it's totally obvious your lips went
from cameron diaz to jay-z
oh my god
who's the wilson sisters
more like the wilt chamberlain sisters
oh my god
i keep telling her i'm gonna break up
with my girl
better hope other doesn't find out she
won't at least until i wrap up this big
deal with your father hey mr v oh yeah
home alone look who just flew in from
the slums
of beverly hills it's the beverly ho
billies we just saw your new video yeah
they had a screening over at saks fifth
avenue in the security office
a kleptomaniac
[Laughter]
your mother shops at
you want to talk about momma
oh no
well your mother is so stupid she
exercises when she could just get like
liposuction or something yeah your
mother's so old
that her breast milk is powdered you
breastfeed like this
oh
whoa
i come from
pocket sand
your mother is so stupid that she goes
to barney's rooftop deck restaurant for
lunch and orders in nisswa salad and
calls it a nikoi's salad
brother's ass it's so hairy it looks
like don king's about to pop out of the
table all in america
ladies i fully expect to see you later
at the white party i think it's going to
be the best one ever
the white part the white part what isn't
that denise porter from new york one
news yeah i'm working on getting you an
interview with her i think i'm gonna go
over there and introduce myself
do you think now's a good time actually
it's a perfect time wouldn't want to
miss a photo op oh yeah
those eyes are so terrified
well if i would have known you were so
beautiful i probably would have called
you myself if i wasn't mistaken i'd
think you were flirting with me miss
wilson flirting with you
a girl never
goddammit you might want to slow down on
the cheese you mean there's
cheese isn't it
dairy uh oh
ladies i think i got to get in a
bathroom oh good we'll come with you
guys
time for touch-ups anyways
[Music]
[Laughter]
i really think that you need to cut
heath a little bit of slack okay because
his aunt just died three years ago and
he
tony hey man my boots cause i'm about to
go skiing
[Laughter]
that's what i'm talking about
a white girl
with a black girl's ass
i'm taking that home to mama
you know what they say
once you go black you're gonna need a
wheelchair oh man
okay call me later
[Laughter]
scary movie for you and now the number
one most requested song on wqr
[Music]
oh my god
[Music]
make my way downtown walking fast faces
pass and i'm homebound
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i can't believe that you just said that
say what
the n-word
so
nobody's around
oh no
[Laughter]
hey i'll know the lyrics
[Laughter]
hi baby
hey what's up baby well i'm getting my
hair done and i was thinking that we
could go to the movies how's that sound
uh
did you give a heads about all of this
here let me help you hold up i'll hold
it open while you put it in okay okay
what is she holding pushing
totally innocuous
oh
so tight tight the only thing that's
gonna be tight is my foot down your
throat you better answer me the perfect
fit
no
what do you think
that
looks
so
sexy
are you kidding
hi i'm cellulite sally look at my
husband
oh no
i think i need a bigger size honey you
never need a bigger size
[Music]
rules for life
i'm courtney wilson before my gastric
bypass surgery oh what about this this
goes on your skin tone
somebody throws shamu back in the ocean
oh my god
i wonder if they let her improv that
stuff honey this is just not gonna work
i'm sorry
of course not you're wearing the wrong
underwear oh yeah
tiff
come on out honey let's see
[Laughter]
that's right
oh yeah
no hulk you break your bike
what
oh my god he's got my gun in patch go
get him
your ass is mine
what is this girl a track star
[Music]
[Laughter]
geez lady all that for a bag
it's not just a bag
it's prada
female empowerment or something
product placement all at the same time
can you believe this i mean they're
actually auctioning off women
well that's uh this was a good cause
besides being wined and died by a rich
guy might be nice
this movie's woke you like rich guys
i mean it might be a pleasant change
from all the losers that asked me out
three thousand that's good
see
twenty thousand dollars oh my god jeez
that is a new record
nuclear opposition benefit who wants to
start the bidding
four dollars
do i hear five
one thousand dollars
nice
five thousand dollars
who
oh my god wowie
[Applause]
oh yes
my feet are killing me
and on top of that that g-string gave me
diaper rash what are you telling your
girlfriend man
damn these girls won't quit
um
we'll be right there we're coming hang
on
[Music]
what did you guys forget it's your turn
to host the slumber party
[Music]
okay
what does it mean
but he just can't seem to break up with
his girlfriend it means you're a total
booty call
sometimes i just wish that they could
trade places with us so that they would
know how it feels you know
all done really
i think you might have been black in a
previous one put shizzle my nizzle
let's go
brittany wilson yeah that's me let's get
her
crack henchmen
[Music]
[Applause]
where are all the other girls you know
just the next room
britney what are you doing those are the
strippers raul and tito chippers
oh
is everything all right here everything
is fine just a little case of pms that's
all could you guys go get me some midol
into snickers right get out of here my
ass is fat don't look at me sharper
chocolate
oh wow we don't see that stripper sage i
feel robbed
i totally forgot my suntan lotion i'm
gonna like go get some suntan lotion
i'll be right back
throw the football with him got a plan
go go go
oh jeez
[Music]
hey yo you do that again i'm a buster
i start in tears
oh my
god don't hurt yourself don't worry
i won't
oh yeah
he's even buffer now
tony
[Music]
oh my god okay
i feel like i've seen you somewhere
um
no no i mean i played pro ball maybe
you've seen one of my games no i mean if
i did i'm sure i would have uh
definitely remembered you oh
yeah
wow
so i was wondering if you know you're
not too busy
maybe we could hang out
yeah sure
this is going so well just go to dinner
okay i'm only gonna be a couple hours
and i'll meet you back at the club
promise i promise
i'm serious dude promise i do need to
use protection tell the trail there's an
extra shower curtain in the bathroom
[Laughter]
a little bit of music
[Music]
how did you know
i love this song
[ __ ]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
what are you doing here i came to borrow
the car and the keys to his house are
you crazy look just call me before you
leave i'll bring it back and then you
meet me back at the club
oh no my brother you got to get your
home it's very rare i have the
opportunity to
bask in the ambiance of such a classy
lady such as yourself
um
captivated by wow
i'll have the steak
smothered in onions a rack of ribs pasta
with extra garlic french fries with lots
of vinegar and a side of onion rings
with lots and lots of sauerkraut don't
just get dairy
[Laughter]
uh it'll be much faster
sorry
tongue is kind of big
oh my god
that sound
oh god
gross
you so can't put it away
[Laughter]
you're shooting under 50 from the
free-throw line okay your turnover ratio
abysmal and on top of that you can't
shoot three-pointers to save your life
so uh
squeeze me buffett's basketball player
of all time
no one's ever cared like that before
[Music]
bask in the ambience
basking in the ambience
this movie's about a bunch of
psychopaths
every one
is a bit insane
i did this piece on warren vandergeld
he embezzled millions and stashed it in
an offshore account
you know you're a good listener
oh [ __ ] smooth smooth what the hell are
we looking for
i don't know
something just ain't right about these
girls
i'm gonna check the bathroom
they left their black penises in there
detachable
you're not gonna believe what i oh
good guys aren't they wow
you really are disgusting hey gay panic
you need to loosen up
there you go
oh goodness
is that britney spears where right over
there
oh forget it she just left
you want to dance
you know that's a great idea here oh
baby let's go let's go no no you put
terry on the dance floor you [ __ ]
deprive us of terry's moves
let's go coyote ugly
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh no this movie cares about a lot of
things yep
[Applause]
we rehearsed
this wow
they're improvising that yep
all of them
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
this is how so many people became famous
on tick tock
we should do the worse
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
this room is so dumb
he knew this was coming pete
[Applause]
no break dance joke is complete without
windmills and head spins
[Applause]
that's what i was waiting for
he put terry on the dance floor if he
knew
that she
is broke
banter guilds broke
[Laughter]
where's the trail
on the dance floor
[Music]
[Laughter]
bring it down terry wilson sisters rock
hamptons
oh no
we've been clowned
[Music]
[Laughter]
this got to stop you know we can't have
love we ain't got trust i know but baby
look okay i was at the restaurant and
the card will go through baby listen if
we don't have trust
we don't have nothing
that's the moral of the movie oh it's
baby it's not it's nothing
he's not what you think he's a man
you're sick come on it's a brave new
world this movie is not whoa
what do they look like
duh us the chief would like to have a
word with you oh my god tiffany what put
the men in black
come on hey people buddy john
chips
i'm honestly forgetting so much about
the actual mission is
[Laughter]
these aren't the wilson sisters no sir
oh no chief chief
check this out oh oh no
i don't know how he he did that
but you can't fake these
oh jeeps
yep
you're both fired turn in your guns and
your badges this operation is over come
on chief you can't fire us i just did
oh man
get him marcus we could do this ourself
it's the next logical conclusion we
kevin this ain't about we i just lost my
wife and my job because of you
so don't tell me about we no more all
right he's explained the whole thing
with your wife you sure you and your
friend can uh get the job done
would i let you down mr v
oh no who who knew turns out that
vandergil's prince was all over the
ransom note triple t
k a
time to totally kick
[Music]
they have learnt now white on the inside
this movie is so offensive but they will
not use the song let's get [ __ ]
we got drawn light somewhere
poor taste begins right there
maybe you could come by around
to
make that 3 a.m
heath you think i'm just a booty call
well not
i'm tired of being your doormat
doormat
honey
what makes you think you're that special
oh what a dick wow
you're gonna regret that i'm so scared
oh my god
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
so glam such couture
[Applause]
[Laughter]
he's ought to get the critics attention
oh no
[Music]
[Laughter]
this will be a nice little treat
they're all going to laugh at you
oh my god what's happening
that's not fine
let's get out of here
[Applause]
looks like some people just don't know
when to quit
come on girl
take matters into your own hands look
someone has got to give those girls a
taste to their own medicine
yeah murder them
revolutionary is so bold and so
so brilliant
of course
everybody they're imposters
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Music]
sure why not
[Applause]
[Music]
so much chaos
protect terry at all costs
hey girl call nae nae and laquan tell
him to bring the vaseline and the
straight razors these [ __ ] on some
other [ __ ]
what
no one messes with my queen
freeze
fbi
you guys take care of those two we're
gonna go after vandeguilt copeland
you're gonna need this
oh
mutual respect why are you doing this
daddy didn't tell you
he's broke
what do you mean bro like like martha
stewart broke or mc hammer broke
mc hammer pro oh
no
are you filming this
are you filming this i'll give you
something to shoot
oh good just got the camera just got the
camera guys it doesn't
[Music]
oh
yeah
good shot
i got you man
man we gonna get that stink now don't
are you telling me
that you
are not yeah i'm not a woman white
deception
didn't somebody tell you this was an
all-white party huh
someone get this [ __ ] away from me
what
kevin
latrell
gina
marcus
[Laughter]
chief
[Laughter]
once again you guys managed to do
everything i told you not to do
you call's over 250 000 worth of damage
oh my god
oh my god
but we couldn't have done it without
gomez and harper all right oh
i don't drive a bentley and i don't have
a house on the hill but i'd really
really really like to take you out are
you kidding me
any man
who would jump in front of a bullet for
me
yeah
love boy
so i'm talking about
just take bullets or chicks
best advice you give to single men out
there
a wheelchair yes but the feeling will
come back i promise
making my way downtown walking fast
faces pass that i'm hungry no he still
gets to win we liked brittany and
tiffany like
so much more when you were there
this means we won't be hanging out
anymore
oh don't say that of course we will
we'll hang out yeah we're gonna all get
together and we're gonna go
[Applause]
[Music]
wow
six people wrote this takes a lot of
people to crack that story it does
it does
one brother was about
you know i want to do a comedy hijinks
about it
this black guy is pretending to be a
white woman and other brother was like
nah we should do like a cop undercover
story yeah
real fbi movie i don't really know what
the furry story is hey we should also
just make a gross out comedy
yeah that was uh
john hurt john heard is he uh guys from
scary movie no it's lachlan monroe who's
john hurt was he the dad richard
he's he's rich dad right
what rich dad the rich dad of the two uh
you know rival white chicks who was
behind at all sir sure yeah yeah there
you go mcallister
from palma from from kevin mcallister
adventures
that's kevin mcallister's dad okay yeah
i think you're right i'm i know a
thousand percent of right about i am
gonna trust your judgment because you
know home alone way better you don't
know home alone enough to know that that
is kevin mcallister's dad that's the
only thing i've ever seen him and then
i'm like oh every time i see him i was
going to call us from dad i mean i've
seen home alone once or twice in my life
you know so it's like i've seen i
remember catherine o'hara of his family
like more than any other character who
is a part of the family
and then the rest of their o'hara he's
the she's the mom
is she yeah
this is why we're the perfect yin and
yang for our recollection of home alone
who's the mom in get out
uh oh um keener catherine keener yeah
yeah right
and who's the mom and back to the future
not the mom but doc brown's wife and
back to the future three
mary steenburgen
[Laughter]
[Music]
i guess catherine right here
you know get all the names mixed up yeah
catherine o'hara and john hurd never
gonna forget now
yeah wow
we'll do a home alone two reaction next
wow this movie would not survive today
it's funny watching it now because this
movie could not get away with a if this
trailer came out today it would just be
so much social media oh my god yeah piss
off at the world
this is freaking this who's 14 year old
brother wrote this mess
this insensitive unwoke mess in a world
of sex positivity
social awareness
the bad horizons trans rights
this movie would just not survive today
no we should do it like i just come out
20 years ago
oh wow it's been my punchline for like a
long time let's let's google the year
white chicks the reason i never watched
it because i just assumed it would be
horrible i always assumed that was what
i was why would you assume that it was
my that's why it was my uh
2004 this is almost almost 20 years ago
okay
yeah um
i i had always
assumed that this would be just a
terrible miserable experience
and i'm not gonna lie the first like 20
minutes
i was like ah why did i say yes to this
[Laughter]
this is gonna be long
and unfunny yeah yeah yeah well it's
weird like keenan ivory wayans directed
you know the scary the first two scary
movie films expected a bunch of other
stuff too and uh gets you sucka and all
those other things yeah and i feel like
there's almost no
flair to his directing in this one at
all yeah it's really like i'm not that
i'm expecting you know filmmaking at its
finest here uh
it's there's no sense of style or like
there's weird editing and it really just
feels like point and shoot just the most
simple [ __ ] while we're on set and let's
get this over with and like
the pace is not as like there's not no
real like snappy rhythm to it like it's
it's definitely
um
that that's the part i'm like i mean if
you're gonna do like your your weird cop
movie that's also infiltrating and
you're actually under recovery you know
there's like a bunch of genres that have
done [ __ ] like that and i thought that
that could have been utilized and i
found myself going there's a version of
keenan ivory wayne's i know that would
have done that
yeah that's what was kind of missing for
me here not that i i didn't even expect
that
um
but when it did get to uh the girls like
them bonding with the with the girls uh
i don't know the name that the trio of
women who though the sisters are friends
befriend like when i got to them
the movie started to like click with me
better and my favorite parts were all
with them oh like if you had one story
there that was like
friendship that really but they're
really cops you know and then yep
there's a lot of things that i think
they weirdly wanted to do but only
touched on so i could slightly feel a
movie that wants to touch on something
a tad more heartfelt and a tad more
meaningful yeah
um about the ways in which men and women
fail to understand one another and can
learn a lot from each other yes yeah
like you had that story then you had you
know the the cop story there was a whole
lot that and i feel like they wanted to
do some social commentary oh yeah
rich white [ __ ] you know it seemed
like there was a lot that they wanted to
do and they just didn't tap into it
really they just did it with the typical
like low brow humor
however
there were times where it was genuinely
really funny all the stuff i really
liked everything with
the girls that was my favorite part of
the whole thing i liked it more like
terry crews is
he he has that star charisma power uh
for sure i really like that a lot
um and i think i'm gonna try to review
this seriously he had star charisma
power
and i really
uh everything else was kind of okay to
me um but
it was that like house bunny mean girls
[ __ ] that i thought was the best part of
this movie yeah 100 like it's funny
because i had the same
thought of like oh this is going to be
so bad it's something it's either gonna
be so bad it's tedious or so bad it's
like
cultishly fun in spite of itself but
that was the thing it's funny because
touching on the tone i feel like that is
the most akin to if it was just trying
to play that straight like it reaches
that tone of like a teen
or like a you know young
like a movie aimed at younger women
about you know friendship and bonding
and blah blah blah like it
most authentically feels like it's
genuinely being that movie and then it's
it's funny to me because you know yeah
it was scary movie and with stuff like
i'm gonna get you sucka like there's so
much
film style that's applied and here it's
like you said the fbi stuff and the
action movie stuff feels like a comedy
director captured it rather than
actually morphing it to a genre
and so yeah it's like that stuff with
the girls all comes off as the most uh
uh
sort of plugged in or the most sort of
well-formed and proportionate partly
because i think it's
it is it's like it appears from the
outside of the core of this movie it's
gonna be the fbi story when really it is
just like a a teen bonding comedy in a
way
yeah i think this movie like okay here's
the bottom line
here's the bottom line about this spell
i have no reason to be nice to this
movie furniture just
incentive to be nice to this film
that
if in terms of like are there moments i
i guess i would say there are moments
that genuinely are like i thought were
hilarious
and then a lot of the times it is just
not working and it's not the kind of
thing where oh it starts off strong and
then it dips it just kind of goes in and
out yeah like sometimes it's really
funny and other times this is like
really flat and kind of tedious and then
yeah
it just keeps switching between them and
you just never know when you're gonna
actually find it funny or when it's
gonna be just obnoxious because there
was like this whole story of
[ __ ] uh damon uh um um
sean wins yeah sorry um sean wayne's i'm
trying to keep it well there's a gaggle
of ways yeah there's a lot of alright
uh
so check you with sean wayne's like
dating this random reporter girl like
okay
like that's one plot like think of all
the plots that are here you have
the the mean girls
uh
i believe that it's jamie king and
somebody else jamie king yeah there you
go so you have the mean girls you have
the trio of the other girls and then you
have
them being undercover you have marlon
wayne's with his wife yeah they have
shawn wayne's dating you have terry
crews you got the other fbi agent other
fbi agent chief you got uh the rich guy
with the plot to steal money or whatever
yeah and it never felt like it it was
like building into something truly
chaotic yeah where it should it's like i
think what they want to do is have this
all like kind of escalate at the fashion
show which it i guess it
kind of did
but it doesn't really feel like a payoff
yeah it feels like a plateau is because
i think too you set yourself up for a
weird position when you're like we're in
one of the most like posh hoity toity
places you could imagine and so i feel
like with that even though the fashion
show does give you some like fun costume
and wardrobe changes and psych eggs and
stuff like that i felt like maybe if
they had really gone to like the height
of opulence for that last scene because
like you know that guy falls into the
tower of glasses but i feel like there
could have been a
greater sense of peril and also more fun
to be poked at like high society if they
really like laid on the gaudiness of
that like parts of it just felt like oh
we got a tent
yeah we can set up all these goofy
stunts in here or something like that
what i thought actually worked really
well for me
because when you see the trailers for
this like this is so dumb like they they
don't even look like real women
you know
it was so dumb yeah who would buy this
yeah what i liked about what this movie
i thought surprisingly did well was just
in this world
no one questioned no way i think that's
so funny so when they're both on stage
they're like
what if it's happening
i'm so confused
it's never an issue
i think that's really funny you know
like everyone just buys it like oh you
got taller you know
yeah everybody creates some kind of
reason to explain it away yeah i think
the i think the handling of that
actually was a really clever way to do
it
because there could have been a lot of
jokes about like maybe they could have
had like one character who who was like
there's something weird about your face
you know yeah there could have been
maybe one but i think actually
i think by everyone buying it it does
create this weird world
yeah yeah it creates the height and then
the sort of uh yeah the fantasy of
the piece
so to speak yeah and it makes it funnier
and it tells you something about the
women that they're pretending to be
mm-hmm yeah yeah absolutely
and and to like i i thought at the end
there was gonna be like oh the friends
are gonna be like oh no we knew it
wasn't you
and so like it was kind of funny to me
that they were that they kept it up till
there were they were just like oh wow
you know we we like you guys way much
more yeah we're bummed that you're not
really them
and uh and yeah like it's even though
yeah it is a mess of a movie like there
were moments like that that were kind of
touching or when uh busy phillips like
actually tells that guy off and like
stands up for herself i was like this is
a nice little scene yeah there's there's
good work
in this movie like as much as like the
writing is is from the past and would
certainly not hold up if it was pitched
now today like oh it's just
like it should have kind of been like a
21 jump street movie of these people
getting in there and they're
experiencing life through a different
lens
you know like dude dear like wacky
hijinks you're mugging yeah your face
and then halfway through you start
really diving into the heart of it you
know
yeah um but
yeah it's because i'm like this is a
long comedy
and it needs almost two hours that's
coming and
i'm like if you're not really gonna
go for the heart if you're not really
gonna go for that you don't need to be
this long you know if you're not going
to go for the heart or inversely you're
not going to really commit to
you know some kind of fbi crime thriller
aesthetic where you're actually pulling
some somewhat impressive looking action
or stuff that actually makes you feel
like you're in one of those movies but
with a comedic twist or something like
that you could have justified the length
whereas here it feels like a very long
series of kind of it like parts of it
feel like a movie and then it feels like
you take break to watch sketches or
something yeah well it's like each each
plot has its own type of sketch
yeah you have the confused like the the
controlling
wife
uh
and and then you have the the buff
basketball black player who's who's uh
is obsessed with white girls you know
and they had a lot of different
things that you just cut back to that
same sketch with it but because it
didn't have any style to it yeah
and
um
i really think yeah it would have just
been better off kind of just focusing on
like in order for them to figure this
out they really have to embody them and
talk to like like do kind of like a 21 i
think i think that's why 21 jump street
actually surprised people because the
plot of that generally would have worked
and the fact that it actually worked
yeah it's something that like oh this
movie kind of needed that but that came
much later than this yeah 21 jump street
does do that where it takes its two
leads and it confronts their comfort
zones and and makes them go on journeys
away from that and here you you you kind
of get that but i feel like you could
have done that in a more meaningful way
that actually complements then sean
wayans trying to establish this
connection with this other woman marlon
wayne's trying to you know uh honor his
wife and also beat terry crews off of
him i guess i i'm weirdly
talking about this in a way that
stretches beyond like did i laugh
because there was i i saw like there was
actual potential here
to make something that just might have
uh
been like a more well-received comedy
mm-hmm there's a there's a better movie
here i think it's already a cult hit
i think it's grown in a cult following
over the years for sure and i think that
there's actually a better movie that
could have been made from this like
it's i'm watching this and i'm going no
you know just a little bit of tweaking a
little bit of focus and some removing of
some things yeah take out a couple plot
lines and streamline a couple others
yeah and like what what is the thing
between like shawn and marlon wayne's
like what
like when they have the all is lost
moment and then marlin's like blaming
him you know i'm like oh yeah i guess i
would yeah sure blame and but they're
not really having a fallout it lasts
like a a second you know i'm like i
don't really
know like about it's because it follows
all the beats you would expect it to do
but none of them hit well because
there's no like finesse on the actual
story like when i like when they come up
with the idea to do the thing i was
expecting some kind of scene where it's
like how are we gonna do this you know
we don't know anything about these women
in this world you know like we got to
figure out something whereas like
figuring out the plan is literally just
like a
okay i got it we're going to get
disguises and it kind of just comes out
of nowhere and then at the end there
when uh marlon wayne's comes back around
you know sean way's about to give up and
then just because the plot needs it to
happen marlin's like no we're going to
get our jobs back and it just feels
perfunctory in those moments yeah yeah
so i think of good but but uh there are
like some the bottom line though is like
were there some really funny moments
yeah
and it it's better
than i thought it would be and i have
put this on a very
low expectation for almost 20 years now
well so it's better than what i thought
it would be like i didn't think i'd walk
away going oh there's actually potential
for a better movie here and
um
it's funny watching it today because i'm
like there's no way in hell this movie
will get away today
yeah so especially with the way how uh
how it it does have an offensive tone to
it in in many ways oh yeah especially
with like the other fbi guys and stuff
yeah yeah yeah they don't like try to
make them look bad
yeah i mean they get their happy wrap up
after like smelling panties and stuff
yeah
yeah it's it's creepy perverted and when
they do to the girls at the
weirder to think about how nowadays
you'd see these scenes they'd be like oh
they sexually assaulted those girls and
the precinct yeah yeah oh yeah yeah i
guess that's how i would you would it
now
that's the funny thing but it's so
stupid in the movie like that i'm not
thinking that at all when i'm watching
it because i'm like i don't think
anyone's really learning from this yeah
i don't think this is that's not how i'm
taking it
but i feel like nowadays if you did that
it would be that's what it is that's
what we're laughing at it does clue you
in i mean it does it does create this
fascinating experience or at least it
did for me where yeah you check back in
almost 20 years ago and ago and go okay
this is what would have been just kind
of like to be expected back then you
know like this is just the kind of
language and voice a lot of these kinds
of semi gross out you know uh
situation based comedies are
and so it's just strange to think about
how yes so very different sensibilities
have become and the stuff that you would
never have really questioned before some
of us might not have questioned before
but uh i think too like
just the central conceit like for as
wacky and chaotic as this movie is like
there is something endearing about the
two of them in the makeup as those
characters like for as much as they are
height and ridiculous caricatures there
is something where like i did get
endeared to just watching them be the
two white chicks like under the makeup
the you know i prefer that when they're
not in makeup two versus when they are
where when they are not in makeup can
care less when they're not in makeup to
be honest yeah yeah yeah absolutely
even though the characters are so silly
and and dumb i thought that they
are they did manage to actually yeah
make me care about sean and marlon
wayans through those characters rather
than yeah just through them themselves
because when they're just themselves
it's just like basic plot stuff yeah
gotta get out of these two troubled
situations and get our jobs back
but the first i i think like
more of like the edgy humor was the
thing i i wish we like when it came to
them using the n-word and the car and
the song like that was a funny ass bit
and it works because of the fact that
you know those are black dudes
underneath that makeup and making fun of
the fact that why people say it and you
know like in private yeah black people
are like it's a funny joke yeah it's a
really funny joke or even terry crews
being a racist at the end yeah being
like you're not white get out of here
yeah yeah those things like they create
this moment where there's multiple
they're kind of interesting yeah i feel
like and people could have wrote it a
better comedy yeah
i didn't feel white chicks
made white chicks i think it might have
been like you could have kept marlon
wayans and uh borrow mine's a lot of
ways that his
humorous style kind of reminds me keane
and i were not kidding i would forget
no oh keegan michael king
all right king of michael key
um
he's a little bit more like
like uh i i don't know
more heightened character more
well-spoken yeah yeah yeah when he does
the characters and i think he could have
been one of these like there's a version
where i can't people probably could have
made a better version of this yeah um
but i think like came people wrote it
and then they started it so it worked
because like sean sean wayans you know
when he's just being when he's just sean
when he's on a makeup he has this like
almost adam's handler quality about him
like he just doesn't give a [ __ ] he
doesn't have a [ __ ] but he's just gonna
be swamped
like at all times yeah i always feel
like i'm watching him on a dating
profile when he's just in normalcy yeah
there's like i'm like are you aware
you're the prettiest wayans like is
there a reason that marlon has to do all
the crazy money and stuff like that
because you're the sexy one
um so
like that's even the dressing room scene
which in the trailer i'm remembering the
part with the g star or the underwear
where it pulls up that's the part i
remember the trailer
but what surprised me about that scene
was how like jennifer carpenter was
really funny in that scene
and um
and uh
and the other girl who was trying to
tighten his pants like that was funny
you know they made
those girls were i felt i was very and
dear to them three of them were great
yeah and like even the dancing was funny
it just sounds so ridiculous like if you
just commit to that level of
some type of
you know
understanding of the sketch in a way i
don't know what i'm really looking for
here um but yeah that that
but it does some type of genre
commitment like as stupid as the dancing
was it's just funny when you see it
happen or the yo mama bit it was so
funny to me just because like yeah this
is what they're going to be good at
blending in yeah it's funny because you
i almost expected
more things like that like you know more
a culture clash and more you know them
calling on the things they know that are
going to be fish out of water here and
it happens but i i guess i did expect
that to be a more
like throughout heavily ingrained kind
of thing because you know there's tons
of fodder to contrast you know
what these two characters know versus
this high class white upper crust you
know very condescending society
you know and and the those
few moments they do that are some of the
better moments across the movie and it
makes you wish that this could have had
maybe like an actual kind of sharpness
underneath some kind of actual maybe
racial or class-based satire or both
sexual like you know like there's so
many opportunities for real satire
across a myriad of different themes like
if this was written nowadays terry crews
character would probably realize that he
likes trans women or something like you
know and not that it has to do that and
not that it needs to be woke as hell or
something like that but you know it's
like you see these weird little
opportunities for interesting contrast
that yes
this is probably the most unusual
when you show why chicks reviews i guess
i'll ever hear because we're weirdly
taking it like seriously like there's a
good movie here
this is like a genuinely like this is
there's a comedy movie here that people
would have really liked
from the get-go surprisingly okay and
yet it could have been so much better
yeah
yes yeah this is not what i was
expecting today and i didn't expect it
to walk i didn't even expect to walk
away from this movie thinking that it
could have been so much better mm-hmm
you know like i didn't think that would
present something to me where i'm like
oh my
just if you got like a seventh rider
[Applause]
that's how they needed just one more
pass yeah just one more punch up uh you
get too many cooks in the kitchen man
it feels like so many writers yeah it
feels like one writer wrote every
different plot thread yeah and then they
all crammed him together and said this
is a movie yeah man in every way and
that they're
yeah i wish there was uh just a better
sense of some type of style to do to the
way it was shot because the shot's so
flat yeah i was surprised by him
like a comedy
kind of
it was shot like kind of
if it didn't have the budget this could
easily feel like an amateur filmmaking
yeah like a mad tv movie
yeah yeah it's just shot like just so
simple
and and i don't think you need to do
like a whole bunch but then like the
editing was also really like yeah just
it was just kind of
like that there's no like momentum to
the
to this [ __ ] there's no visual
consciousness
yeah yeah there's like physical gags so
that's not the same thing and maybe one
or two instances of like an edit that's
fun like when she's braiding busy
phillips hair and then you cut to the
wide and it's all done like like that's
one fleeting moment of like that's a
funny i hope intentional cut or like a
visual comedy moment is more like when
marlon wayne's early on in the movie
with his touch his wife's like you got
home so late
he's like babe and then the camera pans
it's eight o'clock yeah like that's like
that's a visual comedy moment it's funny
but
i don't know
bottom bottom line i i honestly found it
funnier than i ever expected this movie
to be there i was because of one moment
i was like laughing so much i started
crying i don't remember what it was yeah
there was one moment that got me like
tears of laughter
it was just so ridiculous that it
actually got me it's weird that this
movie doesn't hold up but it holds up
way better than you'd expect
all right guys why chicks finally did it
leave your thoughts down below
let's do a pic
michael b i think you make a really good
looking white chick oh yeah
there's some qualities about you that
are a bit feminine michael babe
i can really see it
knife shows you off of sincerity
there's something about you i'm like you
make a handsome man
however
i also do think that like yeah you dress
you up a little bit
there's some rouge on those cheeks you
know you have like the the something
about your lips too it's just a really
he's got supple he does have this like
feature
you either look like paul dano or you
could be a beautiful woman yeah paul
danno could also be a beautiful woman i
don't know about fall down but michael b
michael b
beautiful skin you guys yeah you got
plus you can sing oh man imagine singing
vanessa carlton with michael b
hey that's right michael b can sing he
can sing
your hair is long yeah you're
practically a woman already yeah
we could talk about hormones later
uh
that's a white chick should have been
hormone injections they really go under
there
they get hormones they transition
and then once the case is done they
detransition really face off
no dick off
[Music]